hello
hey there you are i had you turned off
because i was getting ready for the
stream so i just wanted to make sure
you're streaming to your channel okay
yeah let me check my
channel okay we're live right now just
so you know yeah
i'm not gonna drop any bombs or qubits
or anything
all right let's see here
i hear you hello there we are all right
we're on live tony how are you my friend
i'm good welcome back brian so welcome
everybody to
a special edition of our astro bookshelf
hangouts with dr brian keating today
we're going to talk about books
i think right brian right i read 41
books this year
wow 41 and you've interviewed a lot of
really great authors of those books as
well
so at the top of the at the top of the
stream let me just say
go if you don't know about brian yet you
got to figure you got to figure it out
you got to find out about him
go to his channel the link is in the
description box of this video
and subscribe to him he interviews all
the cool kids right
everybody in science that's worth
anything brian knows how do you know all
these people by the way what do you
how do you know every i mean you do know
everybody i was just chatting here with
joe with
john in the chat about that yeah yeah
i'm um
well i've been a practicing stalker for
many years it's kind of okay
nice talk nice talk i wait outside their
kids schools i do all sorts of you know
friendly things because i think they're
lonely no i uh uh
um in my capacity as the co-director of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
and uh that brought a lot of great
intellects here but i
i think you know i really all started
with michael shermer
this past april he had a book come out
he had me on his show
science salon last year when my book
came out losing the nobel prize
and he had me on and i said i want to
return the favor in person why don't you
come to uc san diego for your next book
uh
giving the devil his due which is
somewhere behind me
and uh we scheduled it for you know uh
april
1st or something of this year and uh
there's a little thing called the
covid pandemic going on at that time so
i said in lieu of that
what yeah i don't know what that is
i said instead of coming down to san
diego we'll do a virtual uh
virtual interview about the book and he
then connected me to a bunch of people
i connected him to some people and we've
been going
all all the way since uh since april on
the into the impossible podcast now
we're up to
eight nobel prize winners i've come up
with uh started writing two new books
myself oh really
any any salacious uh gossip you want to
give us on what you're writing
yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna um it's a um
it's a line-by-line transcript of the
brett kavanaugh trial
and um because we have the same initials
brett kavanaugh no i'm just kidding
oh my god now that's where the
similarities end uh
i haven't been an altar boy in a very
long time uh
you might know about this book which i
read uh a couple percent anybody out
there in the audience have you ever
read or heard about this book uh tim
ferriss's tools of titans
no i have not read that one so tim is a
podcaster extraordinaire they call him
the tony darnell
of internet bro podcasting
so i figured i've you know he when he
does the interviews you know top
performers he calls it
tactics routines habits of billionaires
icons
etc and uh and for me i said you know
well i can't really
you know that's not really my brand i'm
not gonna like he does all these
injections with mushrooms and all sorts
of stuff i'm not gonna do that
um you know he's a single bachelor i've
got a bunch of kids running around at
home
uh so what i decided to do is take my
brand which is of course
you know this the uh the nobel prize
right actual noble no i dropped it uh no
that's why you're interviewing all these
nobel prize winners you're you're
pickpocketing their
their medals they've brought them with
them whenever they come to give a talk
here they bring their nobel prizes with
them so
i talked to um so many girls that's all
yeah you better check your pockets when
you get her and what oh i brought it i
thought i had 50 keating here
uh so i decided i'm going to write a
book like tools of titans except i'm
going to call it lessons from laureates
so actually out there give me uh write a
comment
if you like which do you prefer better
in tony streamer in my stream
uh two titles one could be lessons from
laureates for my next book
the other one could be that's a good one
the other one could be think like a
nobel prize winner
so um tell me which one you prefer and
either whatever wherever you're
listening to this
leave it in the comment leave a thumbs
up subscribe to both channels
also support tony please be a patron to
him like i am
uh he does such phenomenal work he's
basically the most
generous uh podcaster in the in the
world that i've worked with
uh all these other people that go on
their shows they're like yeah sure we'll
put you on
uh you know and tony is regular he's
authoritative
he gets great guests and he's such a
good friend please donate to him
please subscribe to me and then we'll
have a crossover but anyway which do you
like better
tool uh lessons from laureates or think
like a nobel prize winner
okay well since i've got you right here
and i've got the mic i'm just going to
say i like
um lessons from laureates and then as
the subtitle you put down
thinking how to think like a nobel prize
winner that's what i think you should do
and uh because you always have a
subtitle of your book that's like some
not you don't but authors do it's his
general statement
uh tend to have a really long subtitle
about what their book is right
underneath that's what i
i love alliteration so you gotta you
know i gotta
uh i like the the first one with the
little laureates so
yeah okay all right good so that's
that's one vote
glorious but anyway yeah so some of the
things i've been doing is talking to
i've talked to like eight
nobel prize winners in the last uh six
months
one of whom i recommend his book which
is a beautiful question
this is a professor frank wilcheck of
uh this guy has more jobs than than like
you know i did when i was hustling to
to make to make my student loan payments
so he's a professor at mit arizona state
uh this uh university in taiwan he
uh he's writing many many books uh of
and he's also been recognized for his
works in basically in poetry
and light verse so i read this book and
then his
um he asked if he could come back on i
said i don't know maybe
maybe not uh but uh he's gonna impress
me the first time around
exactly that's right uh he has a new
book coming out in january so i am gonna
have him back for
uh a second uh interview this the one
that i had last
last week or a couple weeks ago was a
live stream with q
a and uh but i'm gonna do an actual
interview
with him about his upcoming book called
fundamentals
um and that's uh i'm looking forward to
that so this is one of the books i want
to recommend
the uh for your holiday gift giving i
have a link to it in my
uh youtube say it again hold it up
better so we can see it it's uh
a beautiful question so it's it's like i
can't read the subtitle there but what
title is
finding nature's deep design okay
and it's an exposition of the laws of
physics
but told through the language of art so
he's got an extensive
collection on the role of beauty and
symmetry
in art in in music in uh
and and so forth uh and architecture
here's a beautiful mosque somewhere i
think in turkey
and this uh and this embodies in his
opinion
an underlying simplicity and order of
the true laws of nature that he thinks
are
uh you know the question that he poses
is does nature the laws of nature do
they embody
beauty and that's the beautiful question
and i you know so he's in stark contrast
you should know
to uh juan sabina hossenfelder who i had
on the show
this year as well author of the book
lost in math
who takes the exact opposite approach
that beauty is a horrible god for
physics
so i've been looking into this question
asking physicists about this question
and it will continue tomorrow i'm
interviewing uh
leonard malada now which is hard to
spell but easy to pronounce
and he was stephen hawking's co-author
on many many books
yep including grand design and the other
one
i am uh i'm going to talk with him about
is his most recent book
which is somewhere around here uh called
stephen hawking a memoir of friendship
uh so that was a very nice book it's a
little different you're actually
learning more about stephen as a human
being
from the perspective of a physicist so
so anyway so that's one book i'm working
on um
and then i'm also working on well i
should say i'm working on way too many
things
i'm working on an audio book of
galileo's dialogue so right behind my
ear over here
is galileo's dialogue this is one of the
most important books in human history
let me go grab it hold on a second here
my book pile is going to collapse so
this is called the dialogue concerning
the two chief world
systems and um you can buy it new or
used and galileo still gets the same
royalty
but um but i discovered to my horror
when i was reading this book this past
year for the first time
completely reading it's three or four
hundred pages sorry 600 pages
long uh it's no beach read but it's a
wonderful book
and it's so exquisitely written in
beautiful prose
from the perspective of three characters
that galileo causes to interact over a
period of time of three days in venice
sharing laughter insults trading barbs
and so forth
and of course it's led to his house
imprisonment as i talk about in losing
the nobel prize
but uh but the sad thing is there's no
audiobook for this book
so i decided how cool would it be to be
the first person in history
to record the audiobook for this book
called uh the dialogue
and i decided that it would be really
cool so cool that i couldn't do it
uh and so i i conscripted my friend
professor luccio picariello
and he is a professor at university of
manchester manchester university
home of the manchester united football
squadron
and he is italian as you might be able
to guess from his moniker
and he's going to record the audiobook
and i'm working with university of
california who owns the
translation to get the actual
translation into
into print because there's not even an
e-book this is the most what
einstein called this book the forward to
this book
is by a little-known guy and you might
have heard of him
his name is albert einstein so here he
is there so these make great gifts by
the way astro gifts
these are from the unemployed
philosophers guild
and you can get little dolls of all
sorts of famous people
and some of whom have either been on my
show not einstein
but uh carl sagan's daughter and his
widow were on my
show this year to talk about their new
books cosmos
possible worlds that was andrewian
phenomenal book richly illustrated
and then her daughter wrote a book for
small creatures such as we
and i interviewed her and that's a line
from the movie contact
so these are phenomenal authors that i
had on the first mother-daughter duo
in into the impossible podcast history
okay well you wouldn't hang on
uh
can you turn down your speakers a bit
there you go thank you hold on
i'm gonna put on my headphones oh okay
good uh
so yeah because i there was a echo there
so you went through a lot there
and um i just i want to go back uh to
something i had to write it down so i
wouldn't forget
um so the first of all how
how can the university own the
translation
of a book that was written in you know
several hundred years ago
excellent question that's something i
wonder myself
and the reason is they own the
translation so the translation
is a work of intellectual originality
that
uh that they own the the the rights to
so a man by the name of stillman drake
if you can see it down there um stillman
drake is actually the translator of this
edition
that relates to the um 1957
edition now stillman drake is dead too
uh as far as i know
but his estate you know has certain
rights so anyway we're
the our fallback if i don't get the
rights to it which i'm trying my best to
get
my colleague luccio speaks italian and
there's an italian translation
that's only about it's about a hundred
years old
and he can do rendering in real time
with a wonderful
italian-american or italian english
accent
and uh and he's able to actually convey
the feeling of galileo for it'll be also
the first time a physicist
has translated the work of galileo and
uh so for that reason alone
i'm tremendously excited about this side
project
okay well that is cool and uh john
suffels that yes he is talking about
manchester england
uh you know you said university of
manchester right
yes uh yeah yeah the guy you're gonna
get doing the book with the
audiobook with you and uh okay well i
just want to remind everybody i am
streaming on
all the things so please chat and ask
questions and i will we will i'll read
them out and brian and i will talk about
them
um so youtube twitter paris uh
facebook brian's channel and um
twitch all those things so by all means
i'm looking at all the chats so
let us know what you think any questions
and comments so
getting back to the other book the one
about physics and beauty
hold that up again because we're giving
this is recommendations and i want them
to know what it is
a beautiful question you said does
one of the questions the beautiful
question is does is it physics or
science
embody beauty it's uh does nature
and nature embody yes beauty okay i got
that wrong that's
quite a different question because uh
and and so and
implied in beauty i think sorry let me
let me be 100 accurate
the question is a single question does
the world
embody beautiful ideas
so i was totally off many times oh i
don't even understand what that means
yeah well that's why you got to read the
book twice yeah i suppose so but it's
into the audiobook
well all right a related question then
we all science
has all kinds of desires whether it
wants to admit it or not
one of them is it loves simple theories
occam's razor all that crap and then
and it also uh wants to wants to
it finds things like symmetry beautiful
right correct being a cosmologist and i
know you know about
this uh but you're uniquely qualified to
comment on it
on my twitch uh tony's twitch tuesday
day before yesterday galaxia one of the
people who follow
and watch uh right she brought up an
article
uh that showed um i think it had just
come out in
uh after ph i'm not sure uh where there
is a
they were looking at much like bicep2
they were looking
at the polarization signal from the
cosmic microwave background
and in it they found a preference you
know what i'm talking about
they found this handedness preference i
forget which one it was right
it's called birefringence circular
matter but they found
a preference to it so i have two so
first let
your comments on that research then your
comment would be framed in the sense of
what's the big deal
and also i gotta and then i have a
follow-up question on symmetry
yeah but what do you think of that
research because it is related to the
bicep two mission which you worked on
that's right yeah so i had a live stream
about a month and a half ago with sean
carroll
after this paper came out so i actually
i was aware of this paper i was asked by
nature magazine to comment on it
when it came out it's actually written
by two of my collaborators ichiro camazo
and yuto uh me on me and uh they're
collaborators on the simon's array
project in one case and then ichiro is a
member of the oversight board for the
simon's observatory
and so these are very very important
people in uh
in my life in my career and so i wanted
to understand
what this discovery was all about i had
been following this i've been trying to
make measurements
just like this for a long time and uh
and to no avail and so what we decided
to do
is go deep and understand it from sean
carroll's perspective
as he is the one of the originators
of the idea that you could add a certain
type
of breaking of symmetry not adding
symmetry making the theory
less beautiful you could do that using
what's called
a churn simon's term a
a type of violation of lorenz symmetry
which is the symmetry that entails the
invariance
of all physical phenomena independent of
their
location in space their orientation in
space their
velocity in space that the laws of
physics should
be independent of those quantities and
yet it would appear that if this
measurement is confirmed which is far
from being confirmed it
is quite yeah it is quite high in terms
of
uh confidence at least 99
confidence but that translates only into
about a 2.4
sigma uh level of of confidence so it's
not
you know it doesn't many many things are
are later shown to be wrong despite
having 99 or 99.9 or in the case of
bicep
two 99.999 percent chance of
fluke occurrence so we don't quite have
enough uh
data to really support this idea that
the universe has a preferred
axis of rotation so to speak um and that
would be the implication of this
discovery but it is one of the most
interesting things that we can look for
with the cosmic microwave backgrounds
polarization
and this axis of this preferred axis of
rotation they're saying could be one of
the things
that helps explain some problematic
observations we have like this
discrepancy of anti-matter and um
anti-matter and matter and those kinds
of things correct
um so hopefully what do you think
related to that so they're related
yeah so there's something yeah so let me
say what first
what tony's talking about so there's an
excess of matter over antimatter we
believe in the universe
in that the uh the amount of photons we
have in the universe
there's about a billion photons in the
universe for every
for every proton let's just use it for
simplicity's sake
so the baryon uh the to photon ratio is
one to a billion
we think that those billion photons came
from the following
scenario we think that there were half a
billion
protons in the extremely early universe
we're talking about millionths of a
second after the big bang
or less we think that there were half a
milli half a billion
uh uh protons and we think there was
half a billion minus one so 499 million
four hundred nine thousand four
nine hundred et cetera minus one and
that
uh number of antiprotons so when protons
and antiprotons come together
you'd get five hundred uh i should have
said 500 million and one
and then uh protons 500 million
antiprotons and when you combine them
together boom
you're left with one proton left over
and one billion photons and that's where
we think we get it so there's a huge
asymmetry
of photons to baryons but that reflects
a very very minuscule
preference of baryons over photons over
antibarians and for that reason we don't
understand it but andre sacharov the
famous nobel peace
prize winner not physicist physics prize
winner he was a soviet dissident
he claimed that was due to the existence
of uh these different uh properties
called the saccharov conditions one of
which is the violation
of uh symmetry and variance
okay so uh that brings me to
now getting back to the book that we
were just talking about this
so i get so the idea of symmetry is
important
uh it's something that we would like to
see uh happen but it doesn't
seem to happen everywhere it also
correlates quite nicely
with this idea of beauty now in what way
does this book that we're recommending
does it
um does it in any way try to
bring the idea of beauty as a
scientific guide what am i trying to add
as a guide yeah he does
okay he actually goes through this book
and and he comes out with basically
saying at some level
string theory and super symmetry are
kind of the most beautiful possible
imaginable
uh theories and for that reason in con
in combination with other factors that
he goes into
he believes that you know within five
years he says that we will discover
super symmetry at the lhc and
this book was written four years ago so
he's got one year left but uh so far we
have not seen any evidence for super
symmetry
and that was one of the conversations i
had with shelly glashow winner of the
1979 nobel prize
that uh that these questions of of
you know the predictions for many many
decades
that we were on the verge of detecting
string theory or supersymmetry or etc
that these were you know every decade
would come there would be no detection
and then we'd uh we'd continue on as if
nothing happened
and so the question of whether or not
we're ever going to see this is
is a big one and so much so you know one
of my signature questions on the into
the impossible podcast i ask all my
guests
you know what would you put on a
monolith uh as in the monolith in 2001 a
space odyssey
uh what would you put on it that would
represent your values or your
most uh most impressive notions of what
humans have discovered in physics
and uh and kamran vafa the world's most
you know
leading one of the world's leading
string theorists said that he would put
on at the equations of string theory
so imagine a billion years from now or
imagine uh 200 years ago
what would a 200 year old kamran vapha
put on his monolith he might have put on
the ether you know the the luminiferous
ether
is the most beautiful aspect because
it's symmetric it's stationary
and a little wonder so anyway it made me
laugh that that some people
are so convinced of the veracity of
string theory
that they'd be willing to basically use
that as their
summation of all of human knowledge it's
quite startling to me
i know and
while we're talking about this it just
occurs to me that i keep asking the
question well why are these things
beautiful
and and i i don't understand
why things need to be
beautiful for them to be considered in
you know seriously in scientific realm
the the string theory
you know part of it especially uh is
reliant on some
like apparently i don't see it but
apparently it's very beautiful
mathematics
and uh you know plato argued that
mathematics is reality so these are real
regardless of whether we can
we can actually verify any of this
experimentally or not string theory is
real mathematically therefore it's real
in the you know it's just a real thing
regardless of whether we can verify it
stuff like that
bothers me in the sense that it still
seems like and i don't know why it
bothers me but i don't know why we keep
coming back to this idea of beauty
in science because it's not a scientific
thing it's just beauty is i even pointed
out that
you know obviously i know a lot about
beauty okay i mean let's
face it okay yeah you and i are the
just you not me i yeah you're yeah
so i'll take you but you know what do
you know what caused by cosmology and
cosmetology
share the same prefix no seriously
cosmos means beauty it means beauty or
appearance in ancient greek i'm a
scholar in ancient greek in addition to
a bodybuilder and a
and a model um just kidding but uh but
it means beauty
and it means the beautiful face the
universe presents to us and no one can
argue that something about the night sky
is
evocative and maybe entrancing the way a
beautiful person like
tony is but my ques my comment is that
actually they've done studies so if you
take like one of these dolls
um so here's um here's marie curie um
and you look at her she's actually
asymmetric she actually could have made
her a lot prettier than that
i think that they save money by taking
the the gnome chomsky doll who i also
had on the show and
kind of converting it anyway i'm not
going to get into that my friends around
this company
unemployed philosophers guild uh please
uh solicit them for gifts for your
christmas
and hanukkah knee that's really cool i
kind of want some of those yeah
i'll send you one but um but the point
is if you they've actually done a study
so you take a picture of brad pitt
the most handsome man in the world uh
present company excluded according to
people magazine that reputed physical
journal
of great influence and you take people
uh review review letters that's right
they used to have this calendar stud
muffins of science and they had uh
that's no longer invoked but anyway they
take a picture of brad pitt
they take his face they split it down
the middle they throw out one half of it
and then they reflect
his other half over and you could do
this with some beautiful woman
gal gadot or whatever and you reflect
you know i only have eyes for my wife so
i don't know you have to tell me who's
beautiful but anyway brad pitt you take
his face split it in half
and photocopy and paste you know
photoshop all over the other side
and he looks grotesque horrible you know
unviewable
and so perfect symmetry is anathema the
human mind actually doesn't like perfect
symmetry
and that's this thing you know the
uncanny valley is kind of related to
something that's too good a simulacrum
and so i disagree with frank about this
very strongly
not to mention the fact that uh you know
there there's
in my opinion there's this proliferation
of theories based on beauty
and i agree with sabine haasenfelder
who's come on my show and i as i said
both as a guest about her book which is
one of my favorite books of last year
or two years ago uh but also as a guest
on my theories of everything and i've
been doing a lot of talks about theories
of everything
and that's another e-book i'm putting
out so please subscribe to my mailing
list if you subscribe to my mailing list
which i'll put in uh both your uh
your chat room and in my chat room uh
but if you subscribe i've got two ebooks
that i'm going to be giving away for
free one is about the great debate
which is the uh most important debate uh
that
happened in the 20th century and that
involved the size of the universe we
talked about that
uh and uh and then another one about
theories of everything
and um uh and i wanted to you know
really give something back to my
audience including many of the people
that are on the phone or on the
on the screen on the tube right now so
uh so please do subscribe to that
um but the the thing that i really want
you to take away
is that we are you know really learning
a lot about
experiments of everything and how
experiments of everything in the sense
that
an experiment has to be beautiful you
cannot do an experiment that's
ugly because if an experiment is ugly it
means it's not testing
all the interesting applications of the
theory
that it's being designed to put to the
guillotine potentially
in other words every time i do an
experiment tony you know what i do
i do a null test i do a test where i
take the data
and i split it in a certain way so take
this telescope here
the telescope should not know if i am
scanning it to the left or scanning it
to the right
correct the telescope doesn't know if i
took data on a tuesday
or wednesday or i should say the
universe doesn't care if i took data on
the on a tuesday or a wednesday would
you agree with that
that's correct so therefore it shouldn't
care
uh the final data set cannot depend on
the day of the week
so what i can do is take or the season
of the year if it's cosmological the
cosmos doesn't care
that it's about to be winter in the
northern hemisphere right so
for these reasons we split our data and
make perfectly symmetrical
beautiful data sets that should contain
no signal and only noise
we use those data sets to then construct
a model of how our instrument
would perform in the absence of signal
and that is a beautiful thing
we make radiometers telescopes that are
unbiased you've done flat fields
all experiments have to have a beautiful
symmetric
component to them so i agree a lot of
the things i did this year
stephen wolfram's book my friend eric
weinstein does not have a book and
that's
one of the books i'm also working on so
how many books are we up to now
don't tell my wife we've only that we've
done here not just a couple so no no i'm
saying how many am i writing uh
according to you guys oh
all three okay so i'm hoping that i'm
going to help eric weinstein put out a
book
and then about geometric unity his
theory and then um
yeah i went through a couple of the
other ones so far so we've gone over the
dialogue
which i think everybody should at least
read the first couple of chapters only
about 10 or 12 bucks on amazon okay
um and then i had on uh i discussed the
conversation out with frank wilcheck
shelly glashau who also came on the show
recently
he has a book from the 1980s called
interactions and i want you guys to to
look at that you can get that used it's
it's really not such a
such a expensive uh book to read
to but what's so interesting is that
physics has not changed that much
with the exception of a few things the
discovery of
the acceleration of the universe and the
detection of the higgs
and other than that a lot of the
universe and neutrinos
and discovery that neutrinos have mass
although we don't know their mass
so glacial points out about 15 different
things that the universe
that the physicists will learn in the
next few years in 1988
and almost all of them on the ground
report card that he gave to me on my
show
came out to be f's except for one or two
so that's the third book that's
interactions by shelley glashow i have
that in the show notes in my channel
okay um another yeah go ahead
i just want to get to john suffel
because he's going on he wants us to
talk about beginning astronomy books
and what would we recommend for
beginning astronomers and i can take
that one but
first let me just say you're also john
offering people to get a copy of a
norton
star atlas they don't make that no more
and you can't do it so instead of buying
a book
uh the norton star atlas which i have a
copy of
and it's on but i don't want to spend
the time looking for it right this
moment
um and so uh you're not going to get a
copy of norton starlets but for beginner
astronomers
i want to i want this this is called
astronomy 101. it's by my friend carolyn
collins-peterson
and she um it's a very small book
but it's a very accessible book and it's
written
as sort of a crash course for learning
astronomy and space right and it's
divided up into
sections uh of like for example
dark matter what is dark matter uh star
cluster star death
galaxies there's a section on galaxy
formation
and of course the planets each have
their own little section and they're
just
little tiny sections you know you know
the just a few
uh pages on each one like here's here is
one
on the moon and you know it's uh talks
about the phases of the moon what causes
that
things like that a very good book for
someone who doesn't understand what
causes things like the seasons
uh and why the you know the the fazeness
of the moon
the one really she also spent she's also
written several books on the hubble
space telescope so there's a section
on hubble there's a section on the
kepler
uh the kepler space telescope chandra
spitzer fermi
and all these relative these really
groundbreaking
space telescopes and she's also got a
section on
people and of course she there's a
section on galileo johannes kepler
uh the herschel's isaac newton henrietta
swen levitt
uh uh swan levitt uh ed edward hubbell
albert einstein
uh avira reuben clyde tombaugh who
discovered pluto
and mike brown which i found she just
put mike brown in there my
guy who posits this idea of
uh planet nine uh and uh
that says neptune-sized planet way on
the solar system with uh constantine
badigan
and he also was known as the pluto
killer he was one of the people who
voted
against making pluto a planet so
astronomy 101
carolyn collins-peterson great book for
beginners
for just getting started in astronomy
okay how's that john you can't get
norton star atlas so instead of that
instead of that what you can get is
stellarium right on your computer
it is a uh an app that is a planetarium
app you can run it on anything
and you can also get planetarium apps
for your smartphone
uh to do what norton's did and i'm sorry
i'm like you john i love my nortons
but there's a better way of doing stuff
now and it involves sadly computers
phones and tablets so
stellarium is a free program you can
just download it and start looking at
the sky
and it will teach you about the sky in a
way
that norton's would have in book form
but you can't take it out to the
telescope and start you know finding
stars
but there's software for that so you
don't need norton's anymore
sadly but it is a venerable book and i
one that i would highly recommend i have
three copies
which i should probably give away to
people who care about that stuff i have
too many books so i'm
happy to get rid of stuff but yeah how's
that john
do okay okay what else you got for us
brian
well i did this conversation with kamran
vaffa he's an esteem professor
at harvard university a small college in
cambridge massachusetts i'm told
and that book is called puzzles to
unlock the universe or unravel the
universe
and it's a story of how he believes that
you can come to appreciate
very deep concepts in really advanced
physics
through the solution of puzzles and i
got to
have a very fun conversation with him as
i mentioned his answer to the
question of his monolith in space uh
didn't uh
completely resonate with me because of
its reliance so to speak on the
provability of string theory uh we could
talk about that but that
there is a difference between a mystery
and a puzzle
and how can we understand the difference
between
something that may not have a solution
but is mysterious and baffling
such as the uh the existence of
of you know a string theory or of god
you know
something like that or a puzzle which
has a solution
like a rubik's cube has a solution i
joked with him
that you know i'm really good i can get
all five i can get five sides of a
rubik's cube i just can't get that sick
side i can't solve it uh and he got the
joke so you get the joke too
so that was a wonderful conversation
because he's got all these like uh
mathematical
puzzles but they're they're a lot of
them are just about physical intuition
there's like a chess uh kind of puzzle
in there
and you get to see how this great guy
the great mind thinks
uh and how you might be able to sharpen
your mental
uh arithmetic your your mental you know
coprocessor
and beef that up by thinking about
physical laws and he actually gets into
some pretty advanced things in the
concept of
spontaneous symmetry breaking he talks
about gage theories
in a way that you can really wrap your
mind around so that was a really
delightful interview i did this this
past year
uh lenny suskind was a guest on the show
about a month ago i talked to him about
his book
black hole war which is really a book
about quantum mechanics not so much
about black holes
but it involves stephen hawking um or as
some of the people that write me stephen
hawkins
and they they write me and ask me tell
me that stephen hawkins is wrong
but uh but this book is about how he was
wrong in that he
he believed that information uh was
destroyed
when black holes were to swallow up uh
matter that it would erase and randomize
the traces of matter
in the universe and then lenny believed
the other side of the argument
they had this bet uh with john preschel
who's going to be our guest on the show
next month in january stay tuned for
that the brian keating's uh
dr brian keating on youtube and into the
impossible on itunes
and so we're going to talk about that
bet which uh involved at
various times i've heard it said that uh
stephen hawking used to bet
subscriptions to playboy
and bottles of liquor and he was a real
character so i only met him once
did you ever meet him tony no no i met
kim thorne
once said he was a talk at university of
colorado and he bet
he had a bet with stephen hawking but i
never met him no yeah i'm hoping to get
uh kip thorne he's agreed tentatively to
come on maybe
uh in a month or two so it turns out
that he's a rock star to me i love him
yeah so i'd love to have him on his
books influence me greatly
and obviously the movie interstellar is
based on his actual
underlying physical calculations um
other people i had on
uh some of whom do not have books but
yet but will have books barry barish i
had on his
uh interview came out this week on dr
brian keating on into the impossible
and he is working on a book about the
true history of ligo
so how did ligo come to make a detection
of gravitational waves from uh inspiring
black holes
we've talked about that you know i i
love books like that
because you know one of my favorite
all-time books
is the making of the atomic bomb by
richard rhodes and i loved it but i
didn't think i was going to like it it's
about making the atomic bomb the code
you know the
the manhattan project and all of that i
didn't think i was going to like that
but it turned out to be a great story
about how science is done
and it was it was a great book for that
i learned all about people that i never
would have heard about otherwise these
amazing physicists behind the scenes and
and
uh it was a great story so books like
this
with ligo telling the story of how it
got to be done that would interest me a
lot
yeah so the three of them are hoping to
do this
uh to do a book ray wise kip thorne
and uh and also to do uh and also barry
barish but what i found so interesting
and refreshing
about barry barish and and also ray
weiss who i interviewed
that will come out very shortly as well
and that was their
answer to my new question about whether
or not they experience the imposter
syndrome
so i experience the imposter syndrome on
a daily basis whenever i come home my
kids are like who the heck are you
what it is so the imposter syndrome is
this belief that you are somehow
unworthy
of the attention or accolades or
notoriety that you've achieved and it's
really a sense of self-doubt
and uh and it can be quite invidious
that people can
undermine their uh abilities to
accomplish great tasks
depending on the degree to which they
suffer it so a lot of people
are young people minorities in
particular women in science
can can be found to suffer from this uh
because they don't feel like they look
like and they feel like they're
transgressing or in some sense so it's a
very pernicious effect
and i it's just an offhand when i asked
barry barrish i said to him
uh you know what would you tell advice
to your former self on the into the
impossible podcast it's named after
arthur c
clarke's famous third law which is the
only way to find out what is possible is
to go beyond the limits of the possible
into the impossible
and i asked that about he said i said
what would you tell your former self to
do to go into the impossible
and he said don't be ashamed don't be
scared uh
and don't don't be fearful and and
um and and insecure and i said well how
did that really manifest itself and he
said i was um
you know as he's like well i suffered
from the imposter syndrome and i said oh
yeah
and he said yeah i i went up and i said
and he said i still suffer from it i was
like what are you talking about you want
the nobel prize
give me a break he's like no when you go
to accept
the nobel prize medallion you have to uh
sign a book that shows that you actually
received it
and presented your lecture so that you
you know they got their money's worth
this three-inch gold medallion and he
said there's a book a ledger
that is bound in rich corinthian leather
and he opened it up and he looked at
some of the names on the pages before
him and he saw
richard feynman and he saw murray gelman
and he saw he saw this guy albert
einstein
and uh and he got chills and i get
chills thinking about it
so i urge people to listen to that
interview and then so now i'm like well
if a nobel prize winner can have the
imposter syndrome what the heck
help do i have some schlub and uh and so
i've been asking people i asked uh
i asked frank wilczak also winner of the
nobel prize in 2004.
so frank you ever have the note of the
imposter syndrome he said oh god no
so uh so that was uh that was refreshing
uh he actually had a different event
like he felt he should have won the
nobel prize decades earlier he
cut came up with the theory of
asymptotic freedom in 201974
1973 he won his nobel prize 31 years
later
so he was 22 he won it he was uh he was
50
53 he had to wait three decades
everybody telling him you've discovered
why quarks are confined you're
definitely going to win a nobel prize
just any day now
and imagine waiting 30 years like you
don't know if you're gonna live
uh so it's just startling to hear that
he kind of felt like he deserved it
earlier i agree with him
um although he understands why he didn't
get it and then i asked ray weiss
who was a co-winner of the nobel prize
with barry parish you'll hear about his
answer next week
and so i and then i asked lenny suskin
uh who's a friend of mine
i just saw an email pop in now from him
and lenny's kind of a crusty guy
he's been on my podcast now um and i
asked him
would you introduce me to gerard to
hooft
his friend and you know he's actually a
gerard's a nobel prize winner
and i'm just looking as as we're talking
uh lenny sent an email and copied me
to gerard and it said uh brian asked me
if i could get you on the into the
impossible podcast
and i said there's no way i can get
gerard to do anything
but just maybe he should do it because
brian's podcast is excellent
worth doing in my opinion and brian
himself as a professor of physics i
found talking to him to be
pretty interesting so i take that as
highest encomium possible from someone
like
lenny suskin yeah well i my comment on
that
is the imposter syndrome is is prevalent
in science i think
because it is as an endeavor it's a
pretty scary place to be it's
adversarial by nature
yes and so you need to have a really
strong
sense of who you are and what your ideas
stand for
to be successful in science and it's
very
tough to maintain that uh
under constant you know questioning and
adversarial
uh discussions and they're not we're not
talking about mean arguments although
sometimes they can be
that we're i'm talking more about this
you're always defending yourself you're
always
putting up something that says no i'm
right because and you're always working
it
and and it's uh it can it can do a
number on you
uh psychically so psychologically so
yeah i think that's a big source of it
and i think it's healthy that uh people
have this
you shouldn't be debilitating it's hard
it's easy to say
well just have confidence and just you
know don't be afraid
uh it's easy to say that but it's one
it's quite another to have that kind of
conviction
and courage to stand up for something
that
nobody else really believes yet because
this is your idea
and you've got to prove to them that
it's true
that's that's a tentative place to be in
and so you really got to be
strong about it now there there are some
people who have strong enough
personalities it doesn't matter
i can imagine it's it's easy for me to
imagine a great number of people being
insecure in their work uh to the point
where they think that about themselves
yeah plenty of stories where i've i've
tested that myself with people
uh who were less than kind shall you
shall we say
uh but you know i've i've been able to
to push back
in some effective ways to people that
were just being obstructionists so
i i i find that interesting uh that you
ask those people that um
and uh you know and and that you get
this response back from them about what
it's like because it humanizes
what they're doing exactly that's part
of what i want to do and
and uh think like a nobel prize winner
or lessons from laureates whatever the
audience uh
laurie it's how to think like a nobel
prize winner okay good so as long as you
buy 8 000 copies i
will i will name it after you tony
no oh wow okay just dedicate is all i
need um so yes that's one of the
missions of that book
is to humanize the the prize winners but
yeah yeah i have time for about one more
i gotta i do have to go home it's the
end of our hanukkah season and i want to
be there
okay young little ones is this the
eighth night
this is the last night yeah very good
okay okay yeah yeah
so uh i would say the other books that
really influenced me this year
were by people like um you know that you
wouldn't really
expect to be as influential on on a
scientist
but these were ones that i blurbed so i
actually had the opportunity to write
blurbs
that appear on the back of books and uh
two of them really stood out this year
one is called betraying the nobel and
that's by uni turatini
and she wrote a book about the nobel
peace prize that's analogous to the
losing the nobel prize my book
except it's about the atrocities
committed by the nobel p peace prize
committee
and uh and i joke because on the books
the first person to
write a blurb on the back of the book is
the person who wrote the forward and
that's none other than michael
nobel who's the great grand nephew
remember alfred nobel had no
children but it's his great-grandnephew
it's his brother's
grandson and that michael nobel wrote
the
forward and the first blurb and then
underneath that is my blurb
uh brian keating's blurb so i joke this
is the closest to a nobel that i'll ever
get
in real life and the other book that uh
that really you know kind of uh a couple
i did a couple
uh one is by an astronomer and it's
behind me it's called cosmic odyssey by
linda schweitzer she'll be on the
podcast
maybe early next year um and i got to
get write a blurb for her book
uh which is a history of the astronomy
done
from mount palomar here in san diego but
it's really and also an astronomer's
guide you know it helps an astronomer
really understand how uh how
important this device was in
revolutionarizing our understanding of
the cosmos so
i have a blurb on that book let me go
get it because it is available
now you put links on all of this on your
on your description
and uh um in in your stream correct all
these books
so um it's called cosmic odyssey
it's a dense book it's a beautiful book
and it's uh linda schweitzer as i said
she'll be on
it features a a a tremendous number of
gorgeous lavish illustrations pictures
and
really her personal perspective on uh
but but i really found it to be a great
guide so you asked about you know
somebody asked about books for a strong
to learn about astronomy this would be
one because this actually talks about
the history of astronomy but as seen
through a single telescope literally
through a single telescope
all the way up to you know the formation
of the universe black holes
warps and space-time and as i said i was
honored to write
the uh blurb on the back alongside of
robert kirschner
who i'm sure you know and uh uh priya
naratagen who's a
author of uh mapping the heavens this is
another wonderful book i hope to have
her on
so um yeah it's been an amazing year for
the into the impossible podcast
of course i thank you very much for
bringing
it to your massive audience you gotta
thank me it's good stuff so
yeah good work so yeah look forward to
next week i'm talking to
uh lord martin reese he is on the show i
recorded my interview with him this week
[Laughter]
well somebody said you know you've got
to get albert right
at the uh royal astronomical society or
something like that
he's the astronomer royal so that's uh
yeah the royal greenwich observatory and
then yes i
i asked him uh to do my horoscope which
he punched me in the face for that
i would love to do that oh could you do
what sign are you man
just ask him oh you're the astronomer
royal uh what sign are you
so would be awesome oh man he would oh
that would not be
awesome so yeah so please stay tuned for
new and upcoming episodes of the into
the impossible podcast please subscribe
to my newsletter i'll send you guys this
70 page ebook from this conversation i
had with adam reese david spurgle
uh who's the new president of the simons
foundation elect president-elect rather
of the simons foundation coming
uh incoming president and uh and i'll
send you this wonderful
uh book that i've made with images uh
diagrams etc from adam reese wendy
friedman
uh jen 11 who wrote another book that i
love this year called black hole
survival guide
and sarah seeger who wrote a wonderful
book called the smallest lights in the
universe so please do subscribe
her i know that's great
okay tony okay everybody love you all
thank you so much please stay tuned next
year we're going to have as i said john
preskill
martin reese ray weiss and hopefully kip
thorne
and then i'm trying to get uh elizabeth
blackburn who won the nobel prize in
medicine to come on the show
and we'll see it's hard to get i asked a
couple of uh you know there's only two
living women who have won the nobel
prize in physics and so far
half of them have turned me down just
because they don't do podcasts so
i'm trying to get a very diverse
cross-section but it's hard it's hard
because uh
there's so few of them but that's that's
part of the problem with the nobel
prizes you know
i know that you know yes and if i don't
talk to you beforehand
hope you have a great rest of the year
and i look forward to spending some of
2021 with you so
that'll be awesome tony keep doing what
you're doing everybody out there love
you very much
uh thank you for being great fans
podcast grew from uh
60 subscribers in january now i've got
almost 16
000. nice on youtube and then
a bunch on downloads thank you so much
tony have a wonderful
christmas new year's everything you do
all right thanks man
bye my friends all right don't forget to
stop the stream on your channel okay
i'm doing it now